a conspiracy theory has been floating on
the fringes of conservative media for
weeks and now it's made its way to the
White House have you seen anything at
this point that gives you a high degree
of confidence that the Wuhan instituted
virology was the origin of this virus
yes yes that was the President of the
United States indicating he's seen
something that says the corona virus was
made in a Chinese lab he didn't say if
it was from a US agency or from cable
television where he gets a lot of his
information after reports that this
administration has been trying to get
the intelligence community to find a
connection to the Wuhan lab the Director
of National Intelligence issued this
statement saying the intelligence
community also concurs with the wide
scientific consensus that the Cova 19
virus was not man-made or genetically
modified and two weeks ago the US
military seemed to make the same
conclusion on the lab piece that that's
that there's a lot of rumor and
speculation in a wide variety of media
the blog sites etc it should be no
surprise to you that we've taken a keen
interest in that and we've had a lot of
intelligence take a hard look at that
and I would just say at this point it's
inconclusive although the weight of
evidence seems to indicate natural some
Republicans have been trying to point
the blame and public anger at China some
even saying they should simply refuse to
pay China back for the u.s. bonds it
holds the president though said he
wouldn't go that far
indicating more tariffs could be his
response further straining the
relationship between the two countries
and the already stretched bank accounts
of consumers in the u.s. who ultimately
paid the price for those tariffs patty :
al Jazeera